Speaker 1: I want to do a little bit of a
follow up about the Will Smith slap of Chris
Rock during the Oscars on Sunday night.
The American right wing seems to have lost
its mind and are delivering bizarre take after
take about what happened or what didn't actually
happen on Sunday night.
Now I'm going to talk a little bit in a little
bit about kind of what my might.
Now, having had a chance to think about it
more, what my view is on what happened on
Sunday night.
For those of you who don't know, Chris Rock
during the Oscars made a joke about Will Smith's
wife's short hair, which is the style she
chooses because she has alopecia a baldness.
And Will Smith didn't like it, and he walked
up to Chris Rock during the Oscars and slapped
him in the face and then yelled, Keep my wife's
name out of your mouth.
It was an insane situation, and I'm going
to talk about my thoughts in a moment.
But first, let me show you some just bizarre
takes cultural critic and arbiter of ideas.
Dave Rubin said that if it had been a white
person who did the slap, then everybody would
have gone crazy.
And he's mad about that, so he's upset about
how people would have reacted in a different
situation.
What are you even talking about, dude?
Speaker 4: But but because they know no one's
paying attention when you put it above the
machinery of Hollywood, why?
To fabricate something like this that that
Chris Rock makes a fairly innocuous joke,
I mean, she's got a shaven head and I'll talk
more about our vision of SAC, as I said.
And that Will Smith's soul loses control.
He's laughing at the joke at first that he's
so lost control of himself that on an evening
where he knows millions, even though it's
not as many millions as it used to be, millions
of people are watching that.
He's so lost control of himself that he walks
up on stage, calling him bum rush.
The stage right.
He walks up there, smacks the guy and just
sits there.
No security came and got him.
Speaker 1: So far, he's spot on.
I like this analysis so far.
Speaker 4: And nobody, you know, apparently
during the commercials, there were some PR
people saying something to him.
But, you know, we could also add like the
weird woke element of race to this.
So it was black on black violence, which people
obviously treat a little bit differently.
Speaker 1: I suspect that woke element white.
Speaker 4: If Matt Damon had gotten out of
the crowd, very pasty white Matt Damon had
gotten out of the crowd and smacked Chris
Rock.
We'd be there would be riots in the streets.
Speaker 1: OK, so now it's just completely
unhinged.
It's not going to be.
If it was Matt Damon who slapped Chris Rock,
you were not going to see the Rodney King
riots or anything like that.
So the woke aspect of this just a bizarre
take.
He's mad about how people would have reacted
to something that didn't happen.
How is that a story?
Then we go to Fox News, where Donald Trump's
former press secretary, Terry Kayleigh McEnany,
compared what happened to when Michelle Wolf
joked about Sarah Huckabee Sanders and right
wingers were mad, and it has nothing to do
with it whatsoever.
Speaker 3: I would have stopped them, I would
hope.
But because this will Smith, they just don't.
Yeah, I think Trace made the key point.
You know, if it was a fan, it'd be totally
different treatment than it would be for a
celebrity.
And also, I think, very different scenario
when you think too, I couldn't get out of
my head as I watched this.
The White House Correspondents Association
dinner from twenty eighteen, where Sarah Sanders
was so maliciously attacked.
You had Samantha, Samantha Wolfram be whatever
the heck her name is.
Michelle Wolf going after Sarah Sanders for
her appearance and minutes long, excruciating
detail.
And I watched Sarah Sanders sit there, my
predecessor with such grace and poise and
kindness, and just sit there and take it because
if you're a Republican woman, you got to take
it.
If you're a celebrity, you engage in this
behavior and you'll have people come to your
defense.
Jamaal Bowman, another congressman, came to
the defense of Will Smith.
You're a CNN commentator who actually blame
this on Donald Trump coming to Will Smith's
defense.
But if I just may make this one ancillary
point, just like I didn't like the jokes about
Sarah Sanders, I did not like that joke about
Will Smith's wife had a friend who I grew
up with, who had alopecia, and I just thought
it was totally out of back.
OK.
Speaker 1: So again, there it really isn't.
Whatever point she's trying to make is not
landing, and it's always somehow about wokeness
and people and criticizing and double standards
with conservatives.
Last clip here.
This is Sunny Hostin from The View.
Not a right winger per se, but sort of sometimes
a contrarian on that show, or maybe compared
to the others.
In any case, she talks about how this is a
this was an instance of toxic masculinity.
Speaker 3: And I think that when that type
of thing, when you live publicly, you don't
have the right to all of a sudden decide to
execute violence.
And I have to say that was a show of toxic
masculinity.
If he was offended and felt emasculated by
Regina Hall's joke or by Chris Chris Rock's
joke, you don't act out in violence.
That is not a show of love.
That's a show of violence.
And I think that.
Speaker 1: And then lastly, Kyle Becker, the
CEO of Becker News, a former Fox News producer,
tweeting, If Will Smith was a white guy, he
would have been let out of the Oscars in handcuffs.
Then police would have thrown him in jail.
There would be a thousand media hit pieces
about him being racist.
He would be canceled for life.
Instead, he won Best Actor.
That's privilege.
And of course, that's also untrue.
Chris Rock declined to press charges and that
sort of it.
So I have to tell you, there are little pieces
of what these people said that actually do
make a lot of sense.
What we have here was maybe an on a distasteful
joke by Chris Rock and then a physical attack.
These are not on the same playing field.
It's Will Smith is right to be completely
humiliated by what he did.
It's embarrassing.
Number one.
Number two, even if it indeed Will Smith was
sort of standing up for his wife, she was
not in any kind of physical danger, right?
Physically slapping someone would be legitimate
to stand up for your wife.
If it's a defense to a physical attack, there
was no physical danger.
And no.
Number three, it is notable that no security
get involved in any way.
Now I know that it's easy to say, well, security
would.
Never think that Will Smith's going to slap
Chris Rock, there's no reason that they would
do that.
OK.
But it is also kind of reflective more generally
of the academy.
Staff did nothing to prevent this in any way.
They didn't make any effort to explain why
Will Smith stayed in the building after a
physical attack.
The physical attack is completely out of bounds.
And as a big Will Smith fan myself, he should
be completely humiliated by what happened
here.
At the end of the day, this whole thing about,
well, the joke was very off color.
I don't disagree.
The joke was off color.
You're sitting in the front row at the Oscars.
This is what happens at the Oscars.
There's a roast element.
There's a roast aspect to this.
These people make millions and millions of
dollars.
You can take a bad joke.
You don't need to go and physically slap someone.
And Will Smith is unilaterally in the wrong
there.
We'll have these clips on our Instagram at
David Pakman show where you can also let me
know your thoughts about
my analysis.